good evening it is a sound like any
other it will end Wright's Wallace
Stevens in it must change a sequence
whose audible existence at least as
rendered in the poet's voice had until
this fall to a certain extent ended the
lacquer microgroove disk of it must
change recorded sixty years ago this
month on October 8th 1954 at trans radio
studio in Boston under the auspices of
the Woodbury poetry room and its then
curator Jack Sweeney appears to have
been accidentally left out of the Hollis
catalog entry for this series of studio
recordings along with its side B which
featured a complete and subtly
resequenced reading of an ordinary
evening in New Haven
the poetry room which has focused its
preservation efforts primarily on the
fragile format of reels and had
digitized what it thought were the sum
total of Stevens recordings that day
recently refocused its efforts on its
collection of lacquer discs due to the
generous support of the any DCC which
invited us to participate in a pilot
study of its remarkable optical
digitization technology known as Irene
Irene is a touchless technology which
permits archives and individuals to
preserve broken fragile even gouged
discs and cylinders without the risky
intervention of a stylus some of its
representatives are here this evening to
answer questions afterwards in
conjunction with this pilot study my
extraordinary colleague Mary Walker
Graham and I began an extensive survey
of our over 2000 on catalog phono discs
and proceeded to discover and preserve
what we believe to be the only extant
recording of it miss change and to
digitize a much higher quality recording
of their roarers of autumn than was
extractable from the reels wallace
stevens was born in 1879 two years after
Edison's invention of the phonograph
caused the Scientific American to
proclaim
Beach as it were is now immortal Stevens
died in August 1955 ten months after
making the recordings you will hear
tonight at the time of his death we're
now discovering he had recorded two
sections of his sequence notes toward a
supreme fiction it must give pleasure
which was recorded at the 92nd Street Y
in 1919 54 and it must change made for
us the month prior one wonders if he
would ultimately have recorded the
entire sequence if he had survived like
Sylvia Plath Stephens recording history
is condensed into about four years at
the end of his life he was it's fair to
say a recording a verse verse afire
according to a Harvard Crimson article
from the same period
Jack Sweeney is the sort of man for whom
Stevens would overcome his reluctance to
record with his charm and intelligence
he is a person that Stevens could trust
a poem is written as a text over time
but in this case recorded on a single
day a day in which the author had a
cough and that cough and his evident
vocal fatigue changes the particular
iteration and sonic contours of the poem
in the mid century recordings as you
probably know from labels like Cadman
and Argo were still by and large
mimicking The Criterion of published
poetry collections and that they strove
for perfection and definitiveness in
many cases producers and editors remove
the kind of procedural elements in vocal
marginalia that we in our post modernity
often revel in the imperfect to quote
Stevens is our paradise here at Houghton
library through our manuscript rare
books and audio collections you can
experience Stevens poetry as a living
and ongoing entity and the act of
publication is just one point in its
progression you can encounter his
writing as it changes from typescript
with gaps left to permit the passage of
the growing poem to a fair copy made in
pen
his hand to the published first editions
of his books too highly produced and
polished commercial recordings of his
work to the draft like recordings you
will hear tonight in which the audible
slippage as he makes resembles some of
the ways in which his textual drafts
change piece to pierce and reason to
season and reveal a man for whom the
idiosyncratic pronunciation of words and
reinvestment in them of the fullest
inflation and vocalization of their
diphthongs and phonemes tries by a
peculiar speech to speak in order to
accompany us this evening we are going
to project primarily the published
version of the poems retyped by Mary
Walker Graham for this event but in the
case of it must change we're also going
to be showing a few types scripts and
fair copies that are available for
specific sections I shall read the
second a part of notes toward a supreme
fiction the title it must change as I
pass from one part of this poem to
another I shall read the numbers of the
parts one
the old serif parcel builded among
violets inhale the appointed odor while
the doves rose up like phantoms from
chronologies the Italian girls wore junk
quills in their hair and their the serif
saw had seen long since in the Bandos of
the mothers would see again the bees
came booming as if they had never gone
as if hyacinths had never gone we say
this changes and that changes thus the
constant violets loves girls bees and
hyacinths are in constant objects of
inconstant cause in a universe of
inconstancy this means night blue is an
inconstant thing the serif is satyr in
Saturn according to thoughts
it means the distaste we feel for this
withered scene is that it is not changed
enough it remains it is a repetition the
bees come booming as if
the pigeons chatter in the air an erotic
perfume half of the body half of an
obvious acid is sure what it intends and
the booming is blunt not broken in
subtleties to the president our Danes
the b2b immortal president of Danes but
does the body lift its heavy wing take
up again an inexhaustible being rise
over the loftiest antagonists to drown
the green phrases of its juvenile why
should the be recapture a lost blog find
the deep echo in a horn and buzz the
bottomless trophy new horns man after
all the president his apples on the
table and barefoot sevens round him who
adjust the curtains to a metaphysical
tee and the banners of the nation
flutter burst on the flag poles in the
red blue dazzle what at the halyards why
then when in gold and pure a spring
vanishes the scraps of winter Why should
there be a question of returning or a
death in memories dream the spring
asleep
this war is for lovers at last the
compressing their love this being not
resuming this blooming and blooming of
the new come the three the great statue
of the general Dupree rested in Mobile
though neighboring cataracts
bore off the residents of its noble
place the right uplifted poor leg of the
horse suggested that at the final fewer
the music halted and the horse stood
still on Sundays lawyers in their prime
an aids approached this strongly
heightened effigy to study the past
doctors having bathed themselves with
care sort out the nerveless frame of a
suspension permanently so rigid that it
made the general a bit observed change
his true flesh to an inhuman bronze they
never had did never could be such man
the doctors disbelieved the doctors said
that as keen illustrious ornament as a
setting for geranium the general the
very place to pre-impact lund
among our more vestigial states of mind
nothing had happened because nothing had
changed yet the general was rubbish in
the end for two things of opposite
natures seemed to depend on one another
as a man depends on a woman day or night
we imagined on the real this is the
origin of change winter and spring cold
couplers embrace and forth the
particulars of rapture come music
falls on silence like a sense a passion
that we feel not understand morning and
afternoon are clasped together and North
and South are an intrinsic couple and
Sun and rain a plural like two lovers
that walk away as one in the greenest
body in solitude the trumpets of
solitude are not have another solitude
resounding a little string speaks for a
crowd of voices the partaker partakes of
that which changes him the child that
touches takes character from the thing
the body it touches
the captain and his men are one and the
sailor and the cr1 follow after oh my
companion my fellow myself sister and
solace brother and delight five on a
blue island in a sky wide water wild
orange trees continued to bloom and bear
long after the plant is there a few
limes remained where his house had
fallen three scraggy trees waited with
garbled green these are the plan tests
tech-wise and his orange blotches these
were his zero green a green baked
greener in greenest Sun these were his
beaches his sea metals in white sand
patter and the long ceaseless
there was an island beyond him on which
rested an island to the south on which
rested like a mountain the pineapple
pungent as Cuban summer and ba-ba-ba-ba
cool bananas Grill hung heavily on the
great banana tree which pierces clouds
and bends on half the world he thought
often of the land from which he came how
that whole country was a melon pink
you've seen rightly and yet the possible
red an unaffected man in a negative
light could not have borne his labor nor
have died saying
sighing that he should leave the banjos
twang six the Dow me sets barrel to the
crackled blade and you and you the dowel
me as you blow when in my compass you
behold baby RK the bloody rend with L&J
a k the jug felted Robin
pouring out the Dow T Dow V Dow me in my
played there was such idiots in stress a
in rain so many klappas going without
bail
that these be dowels compose a heavenly
Gong one voice repeating one tireless
chorister phrases of a single phrase KK
a single text granite monotony one soul
face like a photograph of fate glass
blowers destiny bloodless Episcopal eye
without lid mind without any dream these
are of minstrels lacking minstrels say
of an earth in which the first leaf is
the tail of leaves in which the sparrow
is a bird of stone that never changes
without him you and you be thou him and
be down it is a sound like any other to
lend seven
after a luster of the moon we say we
have not the need of any paradise we
have not the need that then is seducing
him it is true tonight
the lilacs magnify the easy passion the
Eveready love of the lover his lies
within us we breathe and older evoking
nothing absolute we encounter in the
dead middle of the night
the purple older the abundant the lover
sighs as for accessible bliss but she
can take within him on his breath
possess in his heart concealed and
nothing no or easy passion and never
ready love our of our earthly birth and
here and now and where we live and
everywhere we live as in the top cloud
of am a night evening as in the courage
of the ignorant man who chanced by book
in heat of the scholar who writes the
book pop for another accessible bliss
the fluctuations of certainty change of
degrees of perception in scholars
eight on a trip around the world
Nancy annunzio confronted only men yes
she went alone and like a vessel long
prepared I and the spouse
she took her necklace off and laid it in
the sand as I am I am the spouse she
opened her stone studied belt
I am the spouse divested a bright gold
spouse beyond emerald or amethyst beyond
the burning body that I bear I am the
woman stripped more naked Lee than
nakedness standing before an inflexible
order saying I am the contemplated
spouse speak to me that which spoken
will array me in its own only precious
ornament set on me
spirits Dimond paranal clothed me entire
in the final filament so that I tremble
with such love so now myself and
precious for your perfect II then those
Romania's
said the spouse the bride is never naked
a fictive covering weaves always
glistening from the heart and mind 9 the
poem goes from the poet's gibberish to
the Gabrus of the Vulgate and back again
does it move to and fro or is it both
well is it a luminous glittering or the
concentration of a cloudy day
is there a poem that never reaches words
and one that shatters the time away is
the poem buffed peculiar in general
there is a meditation there which there
seems to be an evasion the thing not
apprehended or not apprehended well does
the poet evade us as in a senseless
element he buried this hot dependent
orator the spokesman at our bluntest
barriers exponent by a form of speech
the speaker of a speech only a little of
the town
it is the give race of the Vulgate that
he seeks he tries by a peculiar speech
to speak the peculiar potency of the
general
to compound the imaginations latin with
lingua franca yep joke on decima 10 a
bench was his catalepsy theater trope he
sat in park the water of the lake was
full of artificial things at age of
music like an upper air like a momentary
color in which swans were serifs the
Saints were changing essences the west
wind was the music motion the force to
which the Swans coveted a will change
the will to make Iris fretting on the
blank there was a will to change a
necessities and present way a
presentation the kind of volatile world
to constant to be denied the eye of a
vagabond in metaphor that catches our
own the casual is not enough the
freshness of transformation is the
freshness of the world it is our own it
is ourselves the freshness of ourselves
and that miss Esther and that
presentation our rubbings of a glass in
which we pair of these beginnings gay
and green propose
the suitable Emma's time will write them
down
you